my question was i'm just trying to
actually you told the doctor about your
finger injury you were asking for coke
it's entirely possible that you were
asking for cocaine and ecstasy objection
yes or no speculation
i'll allow that question answer it
uh clearly uh new white east more whitey
stuff
um is is is uh
yes it's a reference to cocaine
but that doesn't
uh
there's nothing here that says that i
ingested the drug
not saying there is but you were asking
for more cocaine and you were asking for
more ecstasy correct
i wasn't asking for
more ecstasy i was asking for ecstasy
because that was what i was requested
from was requested by my servant let's
let's take a look at the the uk
transcript day three a permission to
approach without your honor okay
day three oh
yeah thank you
i'm sure i couldn't hear you i'm sorry
i'm going to ask you to turn to page 463
and 464 of this please truth
six three four six
are you there i'm there just reading it
sorry and on page 463 line 20
you're asked a question mr depp what i
am asking you about and i think your
barrister mr sherborne agrees the times
we have to factor in it may be we can
put in an agreed local australian time
but what is important do you see is the
order that your finger you have cut your
finger off and straight away after
telling your doctor that you cut your
finger off you are asking for cocaine
and ecstasy
answer
yes that is what it
question that is what it looks like
answer appears to be and it is entirely
possible that i was in the state that i
was in did i read that right
yes you did
asking for cocaine
so we talked about the cocaine and the
ecstasy let's talk about the the
the
ultra
argument altercation that you and ms
heard had in australia
um
you you you testified that you were
sitting on a bar stool right
in australia this is where you so you're
fast forwarding to the
the end of the art
of that argument
yeah we've we've heard we've heard your
account of the argument and the jury
will hear miss herds account of the
argument what i want to ask you some
specific questions about you you're
sitting on a barstool you've had three
or four i think you've said three shots
of vodka i did two or three shots of
vodka yes yeah and you're resting with
your hands kind of hanging over the edge
like that right
uh
well after the first bottle
whizzed past my head and shattered
as i said i walked around the bar
grabbed the larger
was another bottle of vodka the only one
there
the larger bottle brought it back
and poured another shot
and did it
and right and and that that was a like a
what we call a handle of vodka is that
right
well yeah it's one of the larger bottles
with that it's got a handle on it and it
was it was full at the time other than
the shot that you poured
no it wasn't there wasn't a full bottom
okay um and and at some point
before
you you claim you sustained an injury to
your finger you were i believe you
demonstrated to the jury yesterday but
you were resting with your three fingers
um your middle three fingers kind of
hanging over the edge is that is that
fair is that right
uh
[Music]
yes i just had a bottle thrown at me so
i was
when she grabbed the second bottle right
i'm just asking where your fingers were
sir
at that point your fingers were your
palm was facing down and your three
middle fingers were hanging over the
edge of the bar correct
basically that's correct um
and
miss
amber was
seven to ten feet away
correct
once she walked yes once you'd grab the
bottle yes okay and
your testimony and we we've we've heard
it yesterday but your testimony is that
somehow she wound up with this handle of
vodka and and threw it and it it it
damaged part of your middle finger but
what we didn't talk about what i want to
ask you about is it didn't
if it happened the way you said it
didn't didn't damage any other part of
your hand correct no other part of your
fingers
none of the other middle fingers that
were hanging over the edge of the bar
were injured connection compound
we can take it piece by piece
none of the none of the three fingers
that were hanging over the edge of the
bar were sustained to any injury other
than your middle finger is
correct
um
[Music]
the
middle finger certainly took the brunt
of it as the tip and there's
cut off there's no there's no record of
any glass being found in that middle
finger
correct
objection calls for speculation i'm i'm
i'll allow if you can answer it
um
i'm
i'm
not a doctor and i'm not sure what
was
found in the middle finger what i do
know is that when i went to the
emergency room that they
they had to um
inject me with a block to be able to put
it into
a bucket and and take a wire brush to to
scrub it um all clean
because i had
all the makeup still left from pirates
on there and
makeup from pirates okay we'll get to
that in a second but
neither none of the other fingers on
your hand were sustained any injury that
you're aware of correct
uh
no there were
nothing else was separate okay and in
fact it wasn't just makeup from pirates
that was on your hand it was paint that
you would dipped your middle finger into
to write along with blood to write on
mirrors and lamps and
assorted
furniture in the house correct objection
compound
all right i'll sustain it's the compound
there was it wasn't just makeup you
testified yesterday that it was just
makeup from the side of higher five but
in fact after you sustained an injury to
your finger you dipped it in paint in
the house and you wrote in paint mixed
with blood all over the place objection
compound
i'll sustain the objection
you dipped your finger in paint in the
house and wrote on objects in the house
objection compound
that's sustained injections you dipped
your finger in paint after suffering an
injury
yes
and then you use that finger
to write on objects in the house
yes or no
yes that was after i'd um
after writing on the walls the blood had
kind of
dried as it were
and so i
stuck my finger in to a can of paint and
also
excuse me mineral spirits
to
to
put my verbal messages onto the wall and
you use your user finger as a paintbrush
right
essentially yes but you do remember that
there's quite a lot of blood everywhere
including on floors and sofas
well i've noticed i was leaking there
was heat in my finger and it was
i felt this warmth and this liquid and
then
i noticed that the tip of my finger was
gone
and at that point i think i went into
some sort of
shock or whatever is closest to a
kind of nervous breakdown yeah you
testify that
breakdown it's you could have um
also
defaced a painting
by drawing a penis on it didn't you
i've never
i i don't know about that i don't
remember drawing it's penis on a
painting given the state you were in
it's entirely possible that you did that
even if you don't remember it to this
day correct
drawing a penis on a painting was not
the first thing on my mind
i had messages
to uh
write reminders
that were for misheard but you don't
deny that
if a painting was defaced with a penis
drawn on it that could have been you
even if you were blacked out and don't
remember that correct objection
speculation
this was no blackout i know you loved
the word it was no blackout
it was
shock
that wasn't my my question mr depp
respectfully it was you don't deny that
you could have defaced the painting in
the manner that i just described
well given
given that i
had written some messages on the
bathroom mirror and then misheard
added to them
it's also not impossible that miss heard
may have
drawn a penis on a
painting somewhere
i i i
that's not where i was going
okay
let's take a look at page 451
of your testimony in the uk trial please
yes sir
and if you look at page
451
line 21 please
you were asked the question let me ask
you is defacing a painting something
that you are likely to have forgotten
answer i recall a painting on a
lampshade
on a wall on a mirror i remember dunking
my finger into paint thinner and using
paint when i had run out of blood to
paint with and i could have defaced the
painting i suppose but i do not remember
a painting specifically
question down below on 452 line 15
so there are parts of this episode that
you do not remember at all because that
would be quite a big thing would it not
painting a penis on a picture
answer it would be quite a big thing i
do not recall
question it is not something you would
do by accident is it do you
you do not accidentally
answer no i would say not
question you have no recollection answer
i am sorry i'm not 100 sure that i can
say i did that did i read that right you
did read it right sir thank you
let's take a look at exhibit
374 please
mr deb do you recognize this as one of
the mirrors that you wrote on uh with
your injured finger
in march of 2015
uh yes i do
and
yesterday you texted
texted i'm sorry
we've seen a lot of texts today that's
all right i did take someone yesterday
yesterday
you testified that
you wrote on the mirror and i don't i
don't remember exactly what you said but
you essentially said that you wrote uh
things about your past with misheard or
or grievances that you had with her
correct
yes okay um
you're on a permission to uh move or
move this in as an exhibit and ask for
permission to publish any objection no
objection.374 in evidence
you can publish
so
on this which you you wrote on with your
severed finger you wrote
in some some mix of paint or blood
starring
billy bob
and
easy amber
yes sir
miss heard arrived directly in australia
from filming the film london fields in
england
with billy bob thornton correct
that's correct
and you hadn't seen
your new bride
in three or four weeks
and she arrives
you're not happy about her filming with
billy bob thornton and so as part of
this
altercation incident
after
your finger is injured you write
starring billy bob and easy amber on the
mirror correct objection compound i'll
sustain the objection let's pull up
exhibit 375 please
this is mr deputy recognize this as
another
mirror on which you wrote with your in
blood and paint uh after your finger
injury in march of 2015. yes sir that's
in the same
bathroom
okay
you're on a
move for admission of exhibit 375 and
request permission to publish no
objection all right 375 in evidence
publish
can we please
pull up uh exhibit 377.
mr depp um this is a picture of a
lampshade that you wrote on
uh after you sustained a finger injury
on march 8 2015. correct that's correct
you're on our move for admission of
exhibit 377.
no objection all right 377 in evidence
you can publish permission to publish
and
on this lampshade
which appears to be sitting on the
ground
you write
some mixture of blood or paint
good luck and be careful at top
yes correct correct
yes
i thought it was good advice